i'm definitely curious if you guys had
the opportunity to uh to show john one
scene from this movie what scene would
you want to show him and why
oh wow
i
think
i you know strangely enough i think i
would show him the montage at the end
where he sees the success of rent
i know that that's not that that's not
tick tick boom centered but i i just
wish he could have seen you know the
reaction on people's faces when that
curtain came down and because i feel
like you can especially on julie's face
like his sister julie larson
there's a moment where you see her in
the film a couple moments
and i and if he could just see their
faces i feel like he would understand
how important he was and how much their
love his the loss of him affected them
yeah yeah i think that
it's that scene and then it's the scene
of
him
riding his bike through the street and
thinking of lyrics and uh
trying to i can't for the life of me
remember which song that is johnny can't
decide
um
that's just so
jonathan you know he couldn't decide and
so he did everything and
he did it beautifully he did it
correctly
and yet he was questioning himself the
whole time and if someone who's if we
can see someone so brilliant and so
talented be so wrought with self
doubt
um
i i felt seen i felt represented i was
like wow if if we see his genius i then
that means that whatever i'm doing maybe
i'm not seeing mine
one of the things that one of the
messages about the uh
the production and the movie is that you
know what to do with the time we have
and the choices that we make with the
finite time we have um how did being a
part of this
film and this story maybe impact you in
real life and the decisions you want to
make in the future
i mean for for me it was like about
addressing my mental health and how it
exists with my creativity what that
relationship is like because
there was a world that what was
happening to me was that my creativity
was becoming burdensome
and i i i
the way my my dynamic with with
creativity wasn't sustainable anymore it
was the phone where i feel like i was
bullying myself
and
so there was there was kind of like a a
rinsing of that that i faced during the
making of the of this film that was
really important to me
yeah i think that uh
i found uh
a self-love as well throughout this film
uh susan inspired me to just
always choose me
towards the end susan chooses herself
regardless of of all of the different
things that were that were stacked
against her whether it was a
relationship following falling through
or it was uh an injury holding her back
from her highest potential she still
chose herself
and it showed me that i don't do that
enough
and i'm i got to do that more
uh robin you've known lynn for a long
time and you know what jonathan means to
lynn um
what was it like actually watching him
uh on set and bringing this to life
knowing uh just the impact that jonathan
has had on lin's life it's infectious
it's so it's so just like happy and
joyous it's such a good feeling
especially because there's so much heavy
material in the film and
and
some days you do have to sit in that
like i know i'm on my way to your on my
the scenes that were wavier on those
days i had to really i actually had to
get away from lin
because he's so happy that i was like oh
if i interact with him right now it's
not gonna serve the work that i'm about
to do but then it was so great when you
finish those heavy scenes and you got to
go back to him and just because you can
always depend on lynn to bring laughter
and joy because he's just he's always
that little child and you know for him
making this movie it's like watching
someone's dream come true he's wanted to
do this since he was a little kid when
you go on youtube and you type in his
name
you'll find videos that he shot of
himself with his camcorder in his
bedroom
you know so so watching
having seen those videos 10 12 15 years
ago and now seeing him have a
multi-million dollar budget around him
while doing the same thing with that
same energy
yo that's what's up
um for both of you um one of the things
that i love about jonathan's work is the
way he tackles real world issues in his
music and in his stories can you sort of
talk about that aspect and why that's
just just awesome
i think the the
beauty of jonathan larson is his honesty
and is his perspective of of truth
because it's not just his own
and he's able to articulate and emulate
that within his work
he doesn't
he's not queer but he understands the
queer experience through the people
around him he's able to portray that
through his writing
and um that type of brilliance is just
uh unmatched yeah the thing with
jonathan too is like he's just so human
and so connected to spirit when you look
at his lyrics there is like complete
simplicity to them
and
and
especially you know sometimes with with
lyricists they get they get a little
high brow a little bit like
they want to show off and i i don't i
feel like his biggest gift is that he
doesn't show off in his music
and like and even in the characters it's
never like oh there's a bad guy over
there that we gotta fight against one of
my favorite scenes in the movie is your
last scene
because that breakup is so heartbreaking
because it's so human it's not like
someone's a bad person you both love
each other so much there's so much love
there
and within that love and because you
recognize that love love of yourself
love of the other person you clock oh
i need a new boundary
because if i if i don't create that
boundary i'ma stop loving you it's going
to go from love to hate or something
else real quick yeah i mean if you love
someone you let them flourish and if
that
love is liberation it's liberation and
if you are liberated
uh and that means that i'm not there or
liberated without me then i have to
respect that i have to be able to hold
space for that because i i love you if i
didn't love you i i would try to own you
do you know what i mean that's the
difference between like love and
obsession slash infatuation you know and
they're
obviously infatuated with each other
because they like because they're always
loving but also they love each other so
much that they're like i can let you go
and i can support you and i can still
love you from afar but it's hard and it
hurts it hurts so bad yeah
it's so bad
it definitely hurts um on that note i
gotta stop i'm just gonna say again i
really loved both of your work in the
film thank you so much for making it
thank you